Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We have reached in the book of prayer
to the
subtopics regarding the timings of salah
and the times
in which a person is prohibited from
praying and the times which are exempt
which are exempted from those
prohibitions
and we've mentioned generally it's a
general rule of thumb
any optional prayer
which is specified ified
by a specific time,
specific place or a specific occasion
then it is exempted from the
prohibitions or the prohibited times of
praying. So we've given a couple of
examples of that. The author has
mentioned an example
an instance in which the
time
a specific time which is exempt
from the prohibition
which is praying
optional prayers in sets of two
until the imam emerges and rises onto
the meim on the day of Jum for Jum. So a
person is to continue praying in sets of
two until the imam rises upon the meima.
Unfortunately this is a rather neglected
overlooked sunnah. You don't see it
practiced as much anymore. Most people
when they come to the masid for jy and
they're waiting for jy they'll make and
then that's it. So they will make taka
for the masid and you don't really see u
too much prayer after that. The sunnah
is for a person to come in and continue
praying in sets of two. The ideal
instance is to walk into the masid
before
and see that most people are in salah.
Most people are in sat until the imam
rises onto the meimbo in which case
people wrap up their prayer and sit and
listen to the
he gave an instance of
place which is exempt from the
prohibited times of salah and that place
is Mecca. We mentioned yesterday
Haram, right? Mecca
and that is that
we will mention its details here.
We just mentioned it briefly yesterday
morning.
[Silence]
He says,
"And Mecca,
some scholars mention that it is Mecca.
Others say that it is specifically the
masid
a masid of haram
that has the merit of Mecca.
So we know that every
prayer that a person makes in alam
is counted as how many?
Huh?
100,000.
Very good. 100,000. Okay. Now, is that
specific to the masid
or is that all of Mecca?
This is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars. And why does this why
does this even exist? Well, obviously
the original
the essence of something this is
that it is the masid because the
scholars agree that it's not all of
Medina
that multiplies a person's prayer.
It is the masid in Medina and so so on
with masid.
Those are the three mass at which
each prayer is is is counted as much
more than outside of there. And so with
Medina and with masid al it is a
specific number. Not all of Medina but
the prophet's masid specifically. not
all of Kutz Jerusalem but als
specifically. So why would Mecca be
different? That is of course the part
that all the scholars agree on. Some
scholars mention that it's actually all
of Mecca.
Well, where did they get that from? When
we look at
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
Allah says
that he took the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam on the night journey
from
Haram Mecca to Alid and in the verses he
specifies the masid mean
he doesn't say from Mecca to he doesn't
say from Mecca to
he said haram to
Now here's the issue. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam when he was taken
for that night journey it did not begin
in masjid haram per se. The narrations
mention that he was in his aunt's house
and from there he was taken. So he was
not in al masid al haram when the
journey began.
And so the scholars extrapolate from
this and deduce that all of the the the
the boundaries of Mecca. All of the
city of Mecca has that blessing. All of
the city of Mecca has that blessing. Any
salah you make anywhere in Mecca, it is
worth a 100,000 prayers.
And there are other evidences here
and there. however
this is the weaker opinion because
really yes the actual is meaning when he
got on and physically went from Mecca to
masid it didn't start at his aunt's
house. However, the journey directly to
Ala did start from Al Masid Haram
because he was taken from his aunt's
house to the Kaa there. His heart was
taken out. It was washed in a golden
basin of Zam water. In some narrations,
it's zam water. And then it was placed
back into his chest. a clot, a kind of
black clot was taken out of his heart
and Gibl said to him,
"This is the
the the the part or this is the
accessible part of a shaitan from you."
He removed it from his heart. He put it
back in his chest and and then as the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said,
And then my chest was stuffed with
wisdom and knowledge and then it was
sewn back up.
Then the journey began to masid.
So while it didn't technically begin
from his aunt's house, it did
technically begin it it did real
realistically begin as the night journey
from masid haram. And this is a very
important distinction. This is very
important because
one of the things that you will see when
you go to Mecca,
when you go to Hajj, when you go to
Omrah,
going to the masid is a hassle. It's not
easy to go to the masid. There's people
everywhere and you could get separated
and it's tedious. If you want to walk 10
ft, you got it takes half an hour
because there's so many people. There is
a level of chaos. It's not as
comfortable and cozy and cushy as the
hotel. And if you're a real high roller,
you can be up in the hotel with a huge
pain glass window and you can pray
looking down at the cabba right there.
And you know, we're just a little bit
away. So what's the difference? And
anyways, it's a 100,000 anywhere in
Mecca. It's not just at the Kaba. this
finds a lot of people and turns into
a kind of crutch to where you know in
the time I've spent there you see that
even for a lot of people don't go to
thea foraw they don't go to foraw during
the because it's arguably more packed
than
during hajj time and the reasoning is
that all of Mecca has the same reward.
So what's really the difference of
praying anywhere in Mecca or praying at
the Kaba? And this is not what is
intended by what the scholars mention.
However, this is highly debated and the
majority of the scholars view it to
be at alam
not in Mecca generally. The prophet
sallall.aii
am he says to bani and they are the
ones that have the position of a sadena.
a sedana. There are four
primary
services
that are divided amongst the tribes of
of of Quraysh and specifically
beni
the tribes with respect to the services
of the ka. You have a sad you have al
you know the there are four and so one
of them is a sadena which is that they
dress the ka every year and they have
the key to the ka that they are the key
key bearers
and so the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
upon
redelivering the key and keeping the key
and the conquest of Mecca in the tribe
of Bif,
he said to them, "Yeah,
do not prohibit anyone from praying in
this masid at any time and from making
talf
at any time of the day or night.
Right? So in this he tells the the
custodians
or 1/4 of the custodians of the Kaa any
time of the day or night someone wants
to come and pray someone wants to come
and make b do not ever prevent them.
allow this to be open 24/7
any time of the day or night. Anyone can
come and make and make salah. So the
author mentions this as an exemption
as an exemption from the prohibition.
Right? Because if we were to say there
are three times in which a person is
prohibited from praying after fud
before and after
until the sun sets. And we mentioned
this in detail.
It would harmonize with
this narration that we just mentioned.
Allow anyone to pray or make any time of
the day or night.
That is specific to
Alid Haram. That is specific to Alid
Haram. Some scholars say all of Mecca.
the stronger opinion alsa
specifically rather than all of Mecca
because as we've heard all of Mecca
is yes it has some of the rulings of
the Cabba but not all of them not all of
Bless.
[Arabic recitation]